okay I did a street interview and I  asked the guys would you rather have a  girl that gave good head or a good cook  and most guys they want this but I think  before the quick satisfaction I think  that's more for like a one night stand  but what I'm trying to say is that if  you all the women out there and they're  talking about well some of the women  want to be settled down they want a man  right and you've got to think what the  man wants the money interested in that  look at when you when you're doing  Street interviews you're interviewing  single people  look at the people there that are  happily married and ask them what they  do because all the things that the women  out there doing you can be a housewife  you can be going out you can suck okay  just as good as any old [ __ ] on the  street and keep your man and have a man  I'm not going to say that because I'm 32  years in counting Auntie you can't say